hey youtubers is Charlie so Superman
Brannon Roth has just been cast as the
Ray Palmer Adam in season 3 of arrow so
this video is gonna be a breakdown of
that character as well as my thoughts
about how he's gonna fit in with team
arrow Peter Stormare was also cast as
the new count vertigo the new 52 version
of the character he's not a spin on the
Seth Gabel version that we saw in
seasons 1 or 2 or anything like that but
hello to any new people if you're just
finding me for the first time I'm doing
bonus arrow videos while we wait for
season 3 to get here it's gonna be a
little while
be sure to subscribe to get everything
there's even a bunch of comic-con stuff
that's gonna be happening so I'm really
excited so let's just start with the
thought that Superman is coming to arrow
I know Justice League everyone go crazy
it is kind of weird to think about
Brandon Roth playing two comic book
characters inside the DC Universe but
think about it this way Chris Evans
played Johnny Storm and became Captain
America and that went off really really
well so it's like if a brand really
likes you as an actor they'll keep
reaching out to you with new
opportunities I really did like the
Brandon Roth version of Superman and he
was really awesome on Chuck as a villain
but I'm really glad to see him get to
play a big iconic superhero again it's
also a lesson that someday in like a
million years whenever arrow season 1
billion and the arrow movie is over
Warner Brothers and DC will continue to
reach out to Stephen Amell with new
opportunities so it's really nice to see
loyalty from a big brand in that way so
let's talk about the Ray Palmer
character first from the comics just
like with the Barry Allen version of the
flash they did this version of the atom
is probably going to be a mixture of
different versions of the character
they're really good about laying in
Easter eggs from all across the
characters history there have been about
seven different versions of the atom
character over the years and currently
in the new 52 universe the most recent
version has actually been played by a
woman they actually called it the atomic
acara Kerr it was a little bit of a
twist the Ray Palmer version is still
present in the new 52 comics the ones
going on right now but before the new 52
reboot and flashpoint in the Green
Lantern brightest day comic he crossed
paths with Deathstroke obviously played
by Manu Bennett on arrow so I'm hoping
that they tie a lot of these Easter eggs
together he was also featured a lot in
the Suicide Squad comics like the really
really old classic Suicide Squad comics
the most notable atom story that comes
to mind is from identity crisis that
comic was kind of infamous
doing a few awful things to suit in be
Palmer's estranged wife Jean Loring ends
up using the atom suit to shrink herself
and accidentally kills didn't be she had
this epic mental breakdown and Ray
Palmer felt so guilty after it all
happened that he basically just
disappeared they're basically taking his
comic away and bringing in a new version
of the character and that was the way
they did that she ended up getting
locked up in Arkham Asylum they paid it
off later in blackest night but it was a
really big dramatic arc so what does
this mean for Brandon routes version of
the character well he was described as
having a really dark past so I'm
wondering how they're gonna weave in
this Jean Loring story I don't expect
him to do a direct adaptation of the
comics but I think that brendan rouse
character is just gonna be haunted by
some really tragic past events so here's
a breakdown of the origin story for the
Ray Palmer Adam he's the second version
of the character and they've actually
rebooted him several times over the
years but this is the original version
he started out as a physics professor at
Ivy University in New England and found
a white dwarf star meteorite that landed
on earth he used that to make a lens
that allowed him to shrink himself down
during zero hour back in the 90s during
that comic book arc they rebooted the
character and he was turned into a
teenage version of himself for a while
and was able to shrink and grow himself
without needing his special tech just
like all long-running comics they
rebooted the character again made him
older and he had to start using the tech
again but he became a professor and
ended up teaching the Ronnie Raymond
version of firestorm he was also working
with the Justice League at that time but
the funny thing about Ronnie Raymond is
is that that is the stepson of Felicity
Smoak in the comics I know an arrow
they're supposed to be a rape Palmer
Felicity ship but it's just funny the
way they tie their comic book characters
together speaking of ships let's talk
about his relationship with the other
members of team arrow because of the
events of identity crisis and Palmer's
wife murdering suit didn't be it created
a lot of tension between Palmer and the
other members of the Justice League
mostly Hawkman he's not gonna be
featured on arrow but I'm wondering if
Brandon rouse character will have any
bad blood with Oliver Oliver's character
on arrow shares a lot of personality
traits with the Carter Hall Hawkman you
know very dark very brooding because
he's supposed to be a foil for Oliver
this season I'm expecting there to be a
little bit of tension but they are both
superheroes so they will end up being a
team I'm not expecting Brandon Roth to
be full on Adam
with team arrow till the end of the
season I feel like that's like a really
big epic reveal so at least maybe the
mid-season finale before we see that
happen typically they reserved you know
major comic-book character reveals for
that mid-season finale but since it's a
long way to way here are a couple really
important Adams stories for you to read
up on some really good ones are sword of
the Adam it was a series written in the
80s secret origins number 29 is a good
prequel story for the character the
first eight issues of power of the atom
and of course identity crisis are all
amazing stories the atom was also
featured a lot in the classic Suicide
Squad comics so I'm wondering if Brandon
rouse character is gonna have some sort
of historical beef with Amanda Waller
because it seems like anyone who appears
on arrow and as a major character is
connected to Waller at some point if you
don't like reading old comics some
really good Adam stories from the last
couple of years are blackest night and
brightest day that's where the big
Deathstroke crossover happens so you're
asking right now in the comics there's a
female version of the character or
what's up with that right now in the new
52 comics Rhonda Pineda the atomic acara
is what they're calling her is a Justice
League member who's secretly working for
Amanda Waller
more Suicide Squad crossover she's
spying on new Justice League recruits
but it turns out that she's basically
like a triple agent secretly working as
a member of the crime syndicate on earth
three if you've never seen any of the
crime syndicate stories in the comics or
in the cartoons they're basically like
an evil alternate universe version of
the Justice League her version of the
character ended up getting her powers in
a freak lightning storm at STAR Labs and
fell into an experiment that that
universes version of Ray Palmer was
conducting I just love the way they
connect STAR Labs and Amanda Waller to
everything on arrow and in the comics
it's so much fun but what does this all
mean for eras version of the character
it sounds like what they're gonna be
doing with Brandon Rao's character is
combining the more modern aspects of the
Ray Palmer alter-ego and the classic
look of his costume asked for were the
actual reveal of his costume I'm hoping
that they do it at the comic-con panel
but they might wait till they actually
start airing episodes they might wait
till that mid-season finale to reveal
the costume as for changing his
backstory he's supposed to be a tech
genius on arrow but as of right now we
have no idea how he gets mixed up with
Team Oliver I'm guessing it'll have
something to do with the manda Waller
and the new villain count vertigo played
by Peter Stormare plus there's the whole
new flow city ship that was teased in
all the casting notes so I'm sure a lot
of you shippers are asking how Adam
isset II is going to affect all olicity
there might be a few small explosions on
tumblr but I'm hoping they type
Felicity's character to Ray Palmer with
some sort of past event like they knew
each other from some other thing but
it's entirely possible that Felicity
could be meeting him for the first time
in season 3 it sounds like Brandon
routes version of the character is gonna
be about the same age as Oliver you know
even though Brandon Roth in real life is
way older than Stephen Amell they both
look pretty much the same age and based
on the casting notes it sounds like
Ralph's character is gonna be doing
salmon ladders around Oliver anyway so
team arrow might end up helping him
defeat some villain not the other way
around
Brandon routes version of the character
is supposed to be like you know super
huge for now I'm just gonna think of him
as like a big brother that Oliver never
had and I think the atomicity think the
shipping will just be teased for most of
the season we are in our third year and
Felicity hasn't really had a lot of
makeout scene so I feel like she's do
but what if you don't care about all the
shipping and you just want to know about
the villain as for count vertigo I
cannot wait to see Peter Stormare go
nuts he's playing the comic book version
of the character I think Seth Gables
version was just an original spin that
the show did he's still gonna be a drug
dealer on the show pushing vertigo but
because Stormare is just a big cast
think he might turn out to be the big
villain of season 3 Malcolm Merlyn is a
cast regular but he's more of a neutral
figure at this point he could end up
playing both sides so I don't think he's
gonna be the big bad if he do want to
read more about count vertigo in the
comics just read the new 52 version of
the character in the new 52 universe
team arrow actually ended up travelling
to count vertigo homeland to rescue the
shadow characters so I'm wondering if
they're gonna do a roadtrip episode
where team arrow has to rescue Felicity
or someone else it's not quite the super
fun arrow roadtrip I was hoping for but
I am still super excited it's gonna be
awesome broth is an amazing actor and he
does superhero genre really really well
so I think he's gonna fit in with the
arrow cast perfectly I can't wait to see
some of Stephen Amell skew A's and
behind the scenes videos he's really
good about posting videos to Facebook
whenever they're in the middle of
production so it's gonna be a lot of fun
speaking of which what about all the fun
stuff that's going on at Comic Con I
fully expect Brandon Roth and hopefully
Peter Stormare to sit on the arrow
makaan panel Stephen Amell has been
saying he's doing way more than just
that arrow panel that weekend so I'll be
doing tons of bonus videos for all that
stuff a lot of people thought that he
was gonna secretly announce some sort of
Justice League stuff but he totally shot
that down but be sure to subscribe to
get all my bonus videos I'm gonna be
doing a whole bunch of comic-con stuff
there's gonna be a lot of stuff
happening it's gonna be a lot of fun
since I'm posting this today and it's
typically not a day when I usually post
arrow videos I'm gonna try and follow up
later this week with my top 5 Adam
stories so right now you can click here
to learn more about the katana character
the other big comic book character
coming to arrow season 3 and click here
to learn about my top 10 favorite season
2 characters thank you so much for
watching I'll see you guys tonight
high fives
you